el rey del fútbol
de origen humilde Edson arantes do
nacimiento nació en tres corazones un
poblado a unos 200 kilómetros al este de
Sao Paulo el 23 de octubre de 1940 Los
Balones Ya rodaban en casa antes de
saber caminar su padre yo ahorramos do
nacimiento también fue futbolista
profesional la fama y el reconocimiento
llegaron pronto para él con tan solo 15
años debutó en uno de los clubes más
importantes de Brasil el Santos y con la
selección de su país se convirtió en el
jugador más joven en ganar un mundial
Aunque antes de los 20 años ya
deslumbraba al mundo se resistió a los
grandes equipos de Europa y permaneció
casi toda su carrera en el Santos de sus
amores un Idilio que solo fue
interrumpido para jugar dos años en el
cosmos de Nueva York en Estados Unidos
pisó la Casa Blanca varias veces y fue
uno de los impulsores del fútbol en ese
país en cuanto a las cifras Pelé rompió
todos los récords es actualmente el
máximo goleador de la selección de
Brasil con 77 tantos y el único jugador
en ganar tres mundiales fue considerado
por la FIFA como el mejor futbolista del
siglo XX
pese a ser una de las personas más
reconocidas del mundo Pelé siempre supo
gambear la polémica con muchos
admiradores y pocos detractores el rey
encarnó una figura entrañable en
Latinoamérica gracias a esa buena imagen
su relación con los organismos
internacionales siempre fue cercana tras
retirarse del fútbol en 1977 fue
nombrado embajador de las Naciones
Unidas e incluido en el comité de juego
limpio de la FIFA
incursionó en la política haciendo
ministro de deportes de Brasil entre
1994 y 1998 durante la presidencia del
centrista Fernando Enrique Cardozo con
un registro difícil de igualar el rey
deja un legado lleno de historia y goles
un genio dentro y fuera de las canchas
[Música]